appello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovi devono fare il genoa ci
sarà su mike rann parkour pyramid
episodio 2 sono pietro che già ride però
va bene dobbiamo far iniziare
dovete vivido buona io oggi ho problemi
con gli slide marley slime con tutto
lineker c'è problema
una cascata no era un salto stupidissimo
cose qua sotto e non lo so ma credo che
tu non debba andare li chiudono quasi
convinto di questo è sicuro se ci vai
bacci prima tu no di vetro e vetro che
volete vetro muori quindi vedi la faccia
da scoprire qualcosa bene che io salto
con call control ancora anche io esatto
per control che giocato affatto viggiù
guarda che non è difficile come sembra
se ti impegni ce la fai a sei ore ed è
di andare avanti
vai avanti scendi giungessero in mezzo
all'acqua io ti aiuta mi spetta non so
come proseguire ok a sono passato sotto
prima dove sono morto dall'altro
ossigeno al limite se non esco muoio ok
perfetto home gesù no sta roba qua
difficilissima no sei spiegami esci
veloce ma non ti veloce veloce ma che
salta salta
oddio cosa ho visto muore e ti ho vista
e cadendo nel vuoto
vabbè ragazzi sta parte la dobbiamo
saltare purtroppo così perché mi sa che
sia pagato abbiamo distrutto il cambio
molto pavimento si nella mia visuale ci
sei tu che tocchi il terreno e poi il
terreno si fonda tipo come sai sono
troppo forte per questa mappa io davanti
a vico via mai fatto arrivare a mamma
mia sono un razzo sono morto guardate
come vola
volato molto bene ma sì così qua che
sono ghiaccio più saturato più duro si
sa sono tornati indietro servirla a
guardarvi andare di qua
capitolo di andare non sono andato di là
e poi sono tornato indietro come fatto
te lo giuro vero che ho detto di essere
andato avanti ma anche prima ho fatto
così e poi sono da questo tratto
indietro lo può per cui fatto a perché
devi stare sul ghiaccio io ricordi
quando c'era i percorsi ghiacci che
difficile era per me lo ricordo mi devi
slittare da yen
qua c'è un'altra c'è un'altra casetta ok
ma cosa ha detto che non lo so non so
come mai mettono leccese se non le puoi
aprire si serve di per sé come hai fatto
questa era veramente incasinata lo
sapevo già la prima il ghiaccio ma che
le mappe sul ghiaccio io li odio penso
anche pietro no sono come simpatica o
allora opzioni o morto ma tu stamattina
così mangiato con regolazione campane
parkour non ho capito capperi detto
niente lo sparatore robot a caso mai ci
sono no non so cosa ho fatto per essere
così celle da ma io non tocco mai capita
minecraft colpi ecco appunto
si vede che questo è giusto poi giusto
qua è giusto equo e giusto che si
giocano qui è devi rifare un pezzettino
fino a seconda volta che sono caduto gli
pensate molto bene molto bene molto bene
mamma mi ha poi rischiato perfetto sono
bravissimo e adesso devo capire bisogna
fare per fare ma ok ok ok l'avevo vista
ne vada ti freghi
avevo visto prima ce l'abbiamo fatta vai
avanti i piani prioritaria che devi
sempre picchiare perché sapevo che ha
dato avresti fatto tu comunque ragazzi
arrivati al 12 che prima le tv i livelli
ci sono in totale tu lo sai e non lo so
stiamo lavorando che sia ma siamo ancora
dal primo piano moretta e quanti ce ne
sono
teoricamente sono 100 è meglio che tu
non debba fare una roba tipo così a dire
la gente potrebbe starci guarda però non
so dove andrà è vero è bravo vieni giù
non so come ho fatto a non pensarci
prima sono morto sei morto c'è della
lava di software come si fa sta roba
cade gioco sapere la vas mourir vai vai
avanti tu vai avanti
prego prego non capiva il signore io
prima non ho parole si preoccupi
addio quanto è bello stile pop e parkour
abbiamo però c'è cosa richiediamo dove
si va a nomadi lava si sicuro di questa
cosa ma allora sempre game ma allora
stavo scherzando tantissimo ritirato la
terapia detta sta roba
sei un pro gamer stavo cadendo nel
mentre lo dice ciao ma poi schiacciare
un'ora prima di saltare sull'islam
questo lo sai no proprio tipo mezzo
secondo prima o poi schiacciare
tranquillamente cerami a mezz'aria e io
pensavo di prendere il timing giusto o
no può esaltare un bel po prima livello
13 davis e non devi toccare l'acqua
molto te sembra semplice non toccare
l'acqua non mi sembra così difficile
provaci tac tac chiese il gioco manca da
otto anni non gioco mai
ecco appunto ed ecco quando mi
autoelogio faccio schifo questo è un
problema che ci sono mi sono perso dove
si sale in realtà non devi andare a vela
parte li hai fatto tutto un giro
stranissimo non lo so il suo spirito con
l'apporto di montagna o scavando rocce
come co2
ebbene fatto un giro sbagliato tu come
certi vedi sopra l'area no è
difficilissimo di qua fidati davanti
ecco questa parte un pò un casino banca
il tan tan tan sembra un gesto questo
007 questa mission impossible ora è come
si chiama tipo di vice prossimo non lo
so ma invece un impone si chiama ma non
è vero
no no parco lo schifo in terra morto
inquadrato quando finisce stazionata
dove sei arrivato come fanno arrivato
dopo sai è arrivarci a ma [ __ ]
ma questo veramente lega è un genio del
male sto tipo cui ero fatta fammi vedere
di cosa si tratta amico mio
no no no no no no
no no no no no mi spieghi no no no no no
cosa stai facendo
muoio se ho amato nola na dove passare
attraverso il quadro già così è capito
se un quarto d'ora capirlo come ci come
cosa io volevo fare qua non so cazzi
anche se ci arrivo teorico non vedo la
quarta d onore che cosa rosso ii delle
rosse ma ok una volta di porco 2
ecco boh non lo so sai che se dovevi
fare così nota avviene amico viene amico
guarda e ce l'ho fatta a ciccio di fare
insomma quasi bravo aspetta che cipro ce
l'ho fatta stavolta sono bravissimo o
uno bravissimo sono fortissimo vieni
vieni e cristoforo colombo mi ordinò io
all'inizio guardati to sbagli è sempre
così ma non guardava fatti cavoli tuoi
guarda la tv della privacy resta fermo
però sono andato avanti invece perché me
la sento perché io sono fortissimo
philippe arriva c amico 6 scherza è un
pianismo vieni giovani giu vieni vieni
vieni più muoio di baci e papà casa in
scena al vero ci rifacciamo sei potenti
guardo vieni madaio veramente hai dei
problemi a centrali is line mia no
madonna sta cadendo
giusto niente proprio non ti devo
guardare non ce li mette in soggezione
allucinante dove lo so io non ti guai
non lo so io neanche ti devo toccare per
faticare ti guardo e basta tipo chuck
norris è bellissimo ma guarda bellissimo
per te lo è lo so finisco livello nella
porta a casa aspetta non è vero non è
vero ti prego sono vivo per miracolo
vieni qua sono qui vale sta andando a
fuoco
mi sono fatto malissimo non è che lei e
io mi sono cascato mi sono cascato dato
non è italiano mi sono cascato
mi sono cascato o nascostamente squadra
flash e in aria sarebbe ma non lo so nel
pur no devi riuscirci ce l'hai fatta una
volta c'era rifai bravo allora non
guardarlo in girati pirati no cinque
mini di persone ti guardano che io non
ti tocco neanche solo vederti ok go no
si ok ora arrivato a metterti soggezione
ma non sono riuscito
bello 15 nella calca l'area aiuta vi
sono in trappola mora non fosse fuori in
frutta e di pesce dover rendere le
salire e scendere nel salire ma la banca
vuole cuore quando un'ora a fare la cosa
sbagliata per dare davvero di milioni
contro le spore sfogando ciari davanti
l'edera ma anche tu lo so io esatto
avevamo davanti
ecco appunto era facilissimo cosa è
uguale al problema ma perché ancora
vederlo
le cose facili non ci piace non si
genera mamma mia che bel salto come mi
sono emozionato
non penso si possa ce l'ho fatta non
vedo niente non ho cliccato niente ok ok
qua molto bene molto bene dove sto
andando non lo sono anche io ecco
comunque fa veramente schifo vergogna ci
ci hai fatto leggere sei tornato
indietro fi dominare per una persona che
non merita niente dalla vita fra i
schifo hai fatto tutto in guarda
piuttosto che buttarvi giù
mamma mia che schifo ragazzi questo è il
secondo episodio di minecraft parkour
pyramid un casino coltiveremo nel terzo
e ringrazio per aver partecipato come mi
piace che si chiede non cediamo ad un
proxima o video
beh ragazzi non c'è un telecomando però
dove eccolo beh ragazzi
[Musica]